MORNING LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US
FOR THE STATE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE MASON
GENTLEMEN IF YOU SAW A HOG HOG
FLIGHT TODAY IT IS BECAUSE WE
HAVE CENTER HERTZBERG HERE AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE MEETING.
AGAIN THIS IS. WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
QUORUM HERE AT MISSING JESTER
KEY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WIRE.
WHERE PRESENT MORE LOCK
MOORLACH PRESENT BELL YOUR
MORRELL PRESENT HERTZBERG. HERE
FIRST FOR PRESIDENT HER CONDO.
NIELSEN THOSE ARE PRESENT
WIENER. THANK YOU CHEN
MCCORMACK BEEN ESTABLISH WE
HAVE ONE BILL TODAY WE WELCOME
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE
APPRECIATE ALL AS WORK THIS ON
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT
WE'RE LOOKING THIS TO BE
POTENTIALLY OUR LAST HEARING
BUT PROBABLY NOT WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT ANOTHER POTENTIAL
HEARING EITHER NEXT WEEK OR THE
WEEK AFTER. WITH SOME ASSEMBLY
BILLS THAT ARE HEADING OUR WAY
WITH THAT WILL TURN IT OVER TO
THE GOOD CENTER FROM SAN JOSE
WELCOME SIR. OF THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS SO BILL
SB ONE TWENTY EIGHT. IS ABOUT
BEST VALUE CONTRACTING NOW. THE
REASON THIS BILL THIS IS BEFORE
YOU TODAY AS. YOUR SPECIAL
HEARING IS THIS BILL. THE LAW
EXPIRES AT THE END OF THE YEAR
SO WE HAVE TO KIND OF. YOU KNOW
RENEW IT SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE. THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND
THE EXISTING SUNSET. OF THE
BEST VALUE CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTING PROGRAM AND ALLOW
FIVE ADDITIONAL YEARS. WILL ADD
SANTA CLARA COUNTY TO THE PILOT.
CONTRACTS FOR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS ARE SELECTED UTILIZING
LOW COST METHODS AS A RESULT
THE FACTORS FACTORS SUCH AS
RESPONSIBILITY LABOR STANDARDS
DELAYS OFTEN GO OVERLOOKED IN
FAVOR THE CHEAPEST POSSIBLE
OPTION. AND FAVOR CONSIDER SUCH
FACTORS CAN LEAD TO INCREASED
COST AND TOTAL VALUE OR COSTS
OF THE PROJECT. THE BEST VALUE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTING
PROGRAM CREATES A LARGER
CONTRACTOR BUILDING POOL ARE
REDUCES BAD ACTORS INCREASES
THE AMOUNT. SUNSETS AS I SAID
AT THE END OF THE YEAR. AND
WHILE MANY CALORIES ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS WE NEED TO EXTEND
THIS. WE HAVE WITNESSES ALL
TURN OVER THEM THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER BALLOTS ALWAYS GOOD
TO SEE MISTER HUMMEL HERE NOW A
SOLANO COUNTY ABOUT WITH US IN
CASE COULD YOU SEE SIR WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A KICK US OFF.
HERE PLEASE FROM THE FORESHORES
YOUR TWO MINUTES SIR. THANK YOU
FROM AGO ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I REMARKABLE CAPITAL
PROJECT MANAGER FOR SOLANO
COUNTY THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT
THE CARD APPRECIATE SENATOR
BELT BRING THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD. RECENTLY SOLANO COUNTY
SUCCESSFULLY DELIVERED THE NEW
YORK VOCATIONAL TRAINING CENTER
AND FAIRFIELD. THE I. VTEC AS A
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR
DETENTION GRADE RE ENTRY
FACILITY CONSTRUCTED FOR THE
SOLANO COUNTY SHERIFF. IT WAS
90% FINANCED BY THE STATE UNDER
THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS SB TEN
TWENTY TWO PROGRAM. THE FLORA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
UTILIZED THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS TO AWARD
THE EIGHTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLAR CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT.
THE BEST VALUE DELIVERY
OPPORTUNITY ATTRACTED WELL
QUALIFIED CONTRACTOR TO SUBMIT
PROPOSALS TO SOLANO COUNTY
COMPETING BASED ON QUALITY
CRITERIA AND PRICE INCLUDING
RELEVANT PROJECT EXPERIENCE HIM
QUALIFICATIONS AT ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE PROJECT
OFFERED BY THE PROPOSING FARM.
HENSEL PHELPS CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY WAS AWARDED THE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT ON THE
OVERALL STRENGTH OF THEIR
PROPOSAL REPRESENTING BEST
VALUE TO THE COUNTY. HERSCHEL
PHELPS WORK IN A HIGHLY
PROFESSIONAL AND DILIGENT
MANNER TO EFFECTIVELY DELIVER
THE PROJECT DESPITE UNFORESEEN
CHALLENGES THAT AROSE DURING
CONSTRUCTION. IT IS UNLIKELY
THAT THE PROCESS OF
CONSTRUCTING THIS DETENTION
GRADE PROJECT WOULD'VE GONE AS
WELL WHAT DELIVER EQUIVALENT
VALUE BY WAY OF A MORE
TRADITIONAL LOW BID CONTRACT
AWARD PROCESS. WHAT WORKS WELL.
THE PROCESS UNDER PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION A CONTACT CODE
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE CURRENTLY
ALLOWS CONSTRUCTION DOCUMENTS
TO BE 1100% COMPLETE BEFORE
BIDDING. WHICH IS DESIRABLE FOR
MORE SPECIALIZED OR MORE
COMPLEX PROJECT OVER WITH THE
COUNTY WHICH YOU TO RETAIN A
HIGHER LEVEL OF DESIGN CONTROL.
THE COUNTY WAS ABLE TO SELECT A
FIRM BASED ON WHO WILL BE
RUNNING THE PROJECT AND NOT
JUST ACCEPT WHOEVER THE
CONTRACTOR DECIDE TO SEND OVER.
QUALIFIED OR NOT. IT PROMOTED A
COLLABORATIVE ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH THE PROJECT MANAGEMENT
TEAM WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR TO DETERMINE
PROBLEM RESOLUTION INSTEAD OF
JUST GETTING THE USUAL. THE
PROBLEM TELL ME HOW TO FIX IT.
LEADING TO OUTSIDE THE BOX
THINKING ON HOW TO MAKE THE
PROJECT BETTER. RATHER DOWN BY
YOU TO JUST TO GET WHAT IS
MINIMALLY REQUIRED. WHAT COULD
IMPROVE YOU'RE STILL NOT A FULL
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CONTRACTOR
BUT IT'S A LOT BETTER THAN THE
ADVERSARIAL ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
TOO OFTEN ENCOUNTERED AND STATE
LUMP SUM BETTER. WITH A
CHALLENGING PROVISIONS IN THE
LEGISLATION AS IT CURRENTLY
READS DROPPED IT THERE IS A
THOUSAND CURRENTLY STANDS THERE
WERE NO SPECIFIC ISSUES THE
ONLY CHALLENGE WAS CREATING THE
PROCUREMENT DOCUMENTS FROM
SCRATCH. SINCE NO ONE ELSE HAS
DONE IT YET OR HAD DONE IT YET.
BUT THE DOCUMENTS ARE NOW
AVAILABLE FOR USE ON FUTURE
PROJECTS SUCH A LOT OF COUNTY
AND MAY SERVE AS A GUIDE FOR
ANY OTHER CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
ALLOWED TO USE BEST ALL YOUR
PROCUREMENT UNDER THE
LEGISLATION. THIRTY SECONDS.
BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT IS NOT
THE SOLUTION EVERY PROJECT BUT
IT IS CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE FOR
SOME PROJECTS. IT IS USEFUL
TOOL TO HELP. SOLANO COUNTY
SUPPORT JUST BE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH TROUBLE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
HERE TODAY IT'S GOOD TO SEE
SIR. PLEASE WELCOME. MORNING MR
CHER JOHNSON CLAIMED AFTER THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO UNLIKE SOLANO
COUNTY WE ARE ONE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT ARE. IN THAT
PROCESS GETTING READY TO USE
THIS AT THE OR WE'VE BEEN GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF.
UPDATING REVIVING PROCUREMENT
DOCUMENTS REVISING A BID
PROCESS. UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
RUNNING UP AGAINST IT DEADLINE
IN TOUCH. OF THE USES OF THE
ALREADY SO WE WORK WITH OUR
FELLOW COUNTIES TO COME FORWARD
WITH SP ONE TWENTY EIGHT TO ASK
FOR THAT EXTENSION OF FORTY.
FOR THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO'S
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT THIS MORE FOR.
MAINTENANCE ADA. COMPLIANCE
UPGRADES MECHANIC. WORN OUT.
DIRECTLY AS NEW BUILDINGS AT AT
THIS TIME BUT WE DO VIEW THIS
AUTHORITY AS A WAY FOR US TO
WORK MORE PROPERLY WITH OUR
CONTRACTORS AND BOTH SAVE TIME
AND MONEY THANK YOU THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU PROTEST WHEN
YOU'RE GONNA WELCOME ANYONE
ELSE WHO'S IN SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE BALKANS
OFFICER TO HAVE THE HAVE THE
CITY OF INDIAN WELLS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. READ AGAIN.
THE MORNING MICHAEL RATIGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT COULD YOU SEE SIR
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. ASHLEY
WALKER HALF OF MONTEREY COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND-
THINKING AS WALKER THE MORNING.
MORNING RJ RETIRE CHECK AND WE
HAVE THE SAN MATEO COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ACCURACY THERE IS ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORTING PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME. WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
GET OFF FOR ANYONE WHO'S
SUPPOSED TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
LOOKING PROPOSITION. LAST CALL
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS LOOK TO THE VICE CHAIR
FIRST. AT A REQUESTED
LOCATION'S DRAMA YOU MUCH OF
THE PROJECT FOR THE DETENTION
CENTER WAS EIGHTEEN POINT EIGHT.
MILLION BUT IT COST TWENTY SIX
MILLION I'VE JUST. YES IS ABOUT
THE DIFFERENT BILL BRADLEY
THANK YOU THE CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACT WAS ORIGINALLY
EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION AND
CAME AND SOMEWHAT OVER NINETEEN
MILLION BY THE TIME ALL OF THE
FINAL CONSTRUCTION CHANGE
ORDERS WERE PROCESSED THAT WILL
BE INCLUDED THOSE DETAILS WILL
BE INCLUDED IN THE COLORS
REPORT TO THE STATE WHICH IS
DUE TO GO TO OUR BOARD. ON THE
TWENTY FOURTH OF SEPTEMBER AND
THEN FORWARD TO THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES INCLUDING YOUR
COMMITTED CRAP THE TWENTY SIX
MILLION INCLUDES ALL OF THE
OTHER ASSOCIATED COST.
PERMITTING CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT. UTILITY FEES
PROJECT MANAGEMENT TIME. WHICH
ADD UP TO A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF THE PROJECT AS WELL DESIGNED
FEES AS WELL SO THERE'S ALWAYS
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
CONSTRUCTION VALUE IN THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST A TOTAL PROJECT
COST CAN RANGE ANYWHERE FROM
25240% OF THE TOTAL PROJECT
COST DEPENDING ON THE
COMPLEXITY AROUND THAT PROJECT
BUT IT WAS ALL BUDGET. BUT IT
WAS ALL BUDGET IT WAS YES
WITHIN BUDGET AND ON WE'RE
WE'RE IN BUDGET AND SLIGHTLY
DELAYED DUE TO SOME OF THE
UNFORESEEN. CHALLENGES THAT WE
ENCOUNTERED ALONG THE WAY. IS
ARE THERE ARE. REVIEW AND
APPROVAL DELAYS. BUT WITHIN THE
APPROVED. FEDERAL WITH THE
BOARD OF STATE IN COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS YES. THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU SO MUCH WITH
VICE CHAIR. LOOKING FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IN WILL ALSO WELCOME
THE MOTION. THE MOTION BY THE
MAJORITY LEADER ON THE FLOOR.
MR BUT WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. YES
I THINK THIS WILL RESULT IN
PROJECTS COMPLETED MORE
PROJECTS BEING COMPLETED. ON
TIME AND ON BUDGET AND JIBAL
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR
MEMBERS THIS IS A MOTION NOT
RETURN THE BILL TO THE SENATE
FLOOR MISSING CHESTER CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WIRE I
REQUIRE I'M MORE LINE MOORLACH
I BELL HI I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG GUY HER CONDO.
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE KEEP THE ROLE OPEN IN WE
ARE GOING TO HUNT DOWN CENTER
WIENER CENTER TITLE CENTER
ABOUT THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL
WITNESSES THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
PREPARED TO PASS THE AWARD. I
DON'T THINK I BELIEVE HEY THERE
WE GO
. LADIES IN GENERAL WE ARE
IN THE LAST THREE WEEKS THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND WE WANT
TO BE CONSISTENT AND TYPICALLY
HAS BEEN CONSISTENT BETWEEN
THREE INDIVIDUALS OF THIS
COMMITTEE IN REGARD TO THE LARA
WHO ARE THE LATEST THE WINNER
THIS YEAR FOR THE- NUMBER. IN
ORDER HERTZBERG THE CLOSE
RUNNER UP IS SENATOR WIENER. NO
THIRD PLACE AND MOVING UP IN
THE PACK CENTER HER TACO SO.
LAZY GENTLEMAN A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR WEDNESDAY CENTER.
BUT SHOULD WE HEAR ANYTHING
MEANING YOU'D LIKE ME TO DO TO
PRISON THE WAR TODAY THAN WHAT
I HAVE FOR SAY A FEW WORDS. NOT
BAD I MEAN FOR FRESHMAN SENATOR.
CAN'T GET ANY BETTER THAN THAT.
RIGHT OKAY THERE WE GO THEY SEE
GENERAL WHERE THE DAY. ALL
RIGHT CONGRATULATIONS IN AS OF
SENIOR THERE WERE MOST LIKELY
GOING TO HAVE A HEARING OR TWO
UP OVER THE NEXT TWO WEEKS WITH
AS SOME ASSEMBLY BILLS THAT ARE
COMING FORWARD. THE WAR NOW HAS
BEEN DISTRIBUTED AND HANDED OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH
CONGRATULATIONS. THAT LAYS IN
GENERAL WE HAVE ONE BILL ON OUR
DOCKET TODAY THAT'S SB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT CURRENT VOTERS
FIVE ZERO THE MOTION IS RETURN
THE BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
MESSENGER SIR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. YOUR TOTAL I'M
LEANER. WE KNOW HIGH. PLACE IN
GERMAN THAT BILL IS. MORE CLOSE
THE ROLE THAT WAS A SEVEN ZERO
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH LAYS IN
GERMAN AND WE WILL SEE YOU
LATER TODAY THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED AND WILL PROBABLY SEE
IN THE NEXT. COUPLE OF WEEKS